over the last year days and weeks we've
been looking at lots of graphs
I like graphing you get to draw pretty
pictures take some time to develop the
skill but it's time that's well worth it
these are the most recent kinds of
graphs we've been looking at we start to
synonymously call them not just grass
but curves that's because they're curved
okay so I'm going to use the words graph
and curve somewhat interchangeably these
curves are really important we have a
name for this one starts with a PD
remember it's a parabola a parabola and
then this guy over here which we looked
at yesterday is the cubic curve which we
named after this power up here is X
cubed okay now we notice there were
similarities but there are differences
they're both curved they both have some
kind of symmetry there they have
different symmetries to each other so
now the question I want to pose to us is
what about if we push these powers see
there's a two and a three there what if
we push them up higher what happens okay
now we're going to have a look at we're
going to graph these like actually
visually in a second but before we do
that I want you to think about this
numerically with me which is why you've
got a spreadsheet open okay so here's
what we're going to show you know how
whoops that's not what I wanted you know
how okay you tense
we're struggling a little bit I'm not
sure why I don't feel like we have a
good reason for you correct me if I'm
wrong let's try again we have something
tricky and complex to wrap our heads
around are you ready to actually learn
it let me try that again thank you for
at least one response we have something
tricky and complex to learn
are we ready to let it that's better
okay you got a spreadsheet set up all
you need to have for starters is just
the letter X in the top left hand corner
okay now not extra Excel eesti for Excel
anyway oh I get what you mean now when
we were understanding this graph what I
asked you to do was create a table of
values that's what this is going to do
for us but it's going to do all the
legwork for us because as you're going
to see I'm going to ask you to do a lot
of values here's what I'm going to start
with for the cubic curve
do you remember I asked you to do seven
values across here do you remember what
the seven were you've got the present
presuming on your previous page what
were they very good negative 3 all over
2 3
but this spreadsheet here every single
cell is a calculator that can do work
for us let's go a little bit further
let's say go to negative 4 okay now I'm
only doing that on my screen just
because I'm going to struggle to fit the
rest of them you can make yours even lot
like you know more negative you want but
you get enough a pattern from here oh
great let's turn that internet off
that's not helpful okay now I want to go
one for each value as I go across okay
that's what I did when we had a look at
the the cubic curve so to do that if I
say equals this is going to start a
calculation for us in Excel you can
either I think go left on your keyboard
or you can just click on this cell over
here and it'll take that cell and do
whatever you like to it I want to add
one so plus one no big deal okay you
could have typed that just as easily but
now if you go ahead and you copy this
cell you remember what happens when you
copy a formula
it doesn't just copy the number it
copies the instructions behind the
number okay
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
copy that I think I need to actually
click on it and I'm going to paste it
over a bunch of times to get it to
generate all my numbers tada so there's
the first step you can see I've got it
nice and symmetrical so we want to work
out what happens to these powers let's
just start with the powers we already
know okay so this one over here
I'm going to make it X and then I'm
going to teach you how to use this
symbol above the arm above the six if
you go shift you'll get this symbol here
which we actually call the hat okay so
if you go X and then the symbol and then
two in a second on the right hand side
this is going to raise whatever we want
to the power of two okay it doesn't do
anything on the left hand side here
because I haven't pressed equals did you
notice that so it's not a formula right
now it's just the characters but now I
do want a formula so I'm going to go
equals and I want to square the number
above so how do I get it to you know
point to another number I'm just going
to click on that cell up here that's all
there to get that hat the arrow key you
go shifter than six and if I type in two
it will raise it to the power of two
what should the answer be that's great
but the real power of this is you could
have written that just as quickly or
faster manually but now I can copy this
which will not copy 16 it will copy the
formula and then I can paste across
okay so there's x-squared for the next
one I want X cubed and you can see in
exactly the same way I'm going to do the
formula I'm going to click on a cell to
get instructions and then I'm going to
raise it to the power of three in this
case so what we've now created is
exactly what we've accomplished over the
last two days okay except it's just
crunched all the numbers for us okay now
this is a really important point take
your hands off your keyboards and look
up remove it because this is a really
significant 20 seconds okay we're about
to get all the higher powers four five
six whatever you want okay but
importantly before we do it get the
computer do the legwork for us I want
you to make a prediction okay what do
you think the X to the power of four
line row what do you don't tell me I
just want you to figure out it one that
will it look like what about X to the
power of 5x the power of six and so on
what kinds of patterns do you expect to
see what things will be the same and
what will be different I'm going to ask
you to take a moment to actually go to
your book
see how here it says what about higher
powers underneath there I want you to
make some predictions make two or three
or four heaven you can pick off what
will be the same what will be different
I'll give you about a minute to write
some things down